[Music]
the cast of the eternals were just
exposed
and to keep everyone safe those
superheroes are now in super isolation
a source tells et the cancellation came
just 20 minutes before the l ceremony
was slated to begin and although angie
salma gemma and lauren tested negative
the decision was made out of an
abundance of caution the presenter
scrambled selma conveniently sent me her
remarks
demi moore read salma's speech eva
longoria delivered angelina's remarks it
is a gift to be a woman
jimma sent a video i'm so sorry that i
can't be with you this evening the
eternal's cast is now pivoting to
virtual appearances that includes our
interview tomorrow which was originally
going to be in person
also honored last night rita moreno
jennifer hudson and halle berry who
gushed over boyfriend van hunt to my
love love love my sweetheart van hunt
every good woman has a good man behind
her why is it that you love him so much
i mean because it's fun it's my time it
was finally my time and and and the
right one finally showed up
honoree gal gadot hit the red carpet in
hot pink i know linda carter made a
cameo in 1984 but three years ago and
you guys are going to be together on the
screen yeah
can we see your babies in this one again
because we know your husband and your
two daughters were in there we might i
can get used to it it's a nice souvenir
and just like that's nicole ari parker
clearing up sex and the city rumors
everybody's like
you know the new samantha and i'm like
no first of all there's four new
characters of color that have been added
to the show but you know it's still to
say there's lots of sex being had
in the city